my guest this week is a youtuber a
free-speech activist immense rights
activists and more than meets the eye
Blair white welcome to the Rubin report
hi Dave thanks for having me thanks for
doing this you know every couple weeks I
suddenly get a burst of tweets where
people are saying this is the person you
got to talk to now and you were the
person over the past couple weeks that
everyone said you've got to talk to
Blair let's make it happen
yeah ever since I started YouTube I've
gotten a ton of people saying that we
need to do a talk we need to you know
collaborate on something so I'm have a
friendly doing it yeah all right well we
do have a lot in common in terms of all
the social justice stuff and free speech
stuff and you really put yourself out
there and totally unapologetic and you
let it fly so I'm looking forward to
this so let's start with some of the
trans stuff because I feel like you're
probably bored in some way by talking
about it but it does kind of frame a
little bit of this maybe maybe you're
not bored I don't wanna put words in
your mouth when did you realize that you
were trans so the realization that I was
transgender definitely came a little bit
later in life when I was younger I
definitely had a feeling of you know
disconnect between myself perception and
the way that other people interacted
with me as early as probably four or
five I remember feeling like something
just wasn't right I couldn't necessarily
put my finger on it or you know figure
out what the word for it was as I got
older I kind of realized that I was able
to take my life into my own hands and do
what the metal medical community calls
transition and you know live my life how
I saw fit yeah so when did you first you
know you're four or five years old you
realize something's a little different
or a little off or however I want to
phrase it like what do you have idea of
an example of like what made you think
there's something going on here I
remember being in kindergarten and
feeling like all the activities that
were you know segregated amongst the
sexes I always had a natural inclination
to want to do what the girls were
assigned to do in there you know putting
backpacks away and the pink and blue
cubbies I always wanted to pink one not
because it was an aesthetic thing like
oh I like pink it was more because I
literally felt like that was where I was
supposed to be yeah and then what about
as you got a little bit older so now
you're four or five you're now maybe in
like
junior-high was with those trends just
continuing or is there anything else
that was popping up yeah that thread
definitely continued throughout my life
once I started to get a little bit
closer to puberty so like junior high I
started noticing some bodily changes
obviously puberty and that was when I
started to develop what they call gender
dysphoria and that is basically feeling
like I said the disconnect between your
body and the way people perceive you
yeah
so I realized through going through that
that I needed to transition and as I got
older and how the financial means I
definitely put that into motion yeah
when you realize that you wanted to
transition did you know what it was
exactly because I think one of the
reasons that I think so much of when we
talk about transgendered people and
these issues people don't even
understand like the basic stuff between
what a crossdresser is and what a
transgendered person is or you know all
of this gets lumped together as part of
the LGBTQI community and there's a lot
of differences within those letters did
you realize oh this is actually
something that I can do uh yeah
definitely as I got older it's you know
the desire to transition wasn't
necessarily that it was more of like I'm
not comfortable with the way my body is
changing I'm not comfortable the way the
world is perceiving me and it took
learning what transitioning was to
understand well this might be my ticket
you know being being happy and it
definitely was um you know I'm not one
of those people don't have those trans
people who thinks that anyone who feels
any type of you know dysphoria whatever
need to transition I think it's the
wrong decision for some people and some
people do regret it I think that there
is a small number of people who
transition is the right decision
through-and-through I happen to be one
of those people I think it's it's worked
out pretty well for me um but I do
acknowledge that it's not the smartest
thing for everyone that's interesting so
you think there are some trans people
who could be potentially in the same
sort of situation that you were in but
actually going through the process might
not ultimately be the best situation for
them
yeah I mean if you look at the suicide
rates for the trans community they're
extremely high and a lot of times
they're almost the same
even after transition so for that reason
it makes me think well maybe transition
isn't the right choice for everyone um
that's just my opinion obviously I'm a
believer in freedom Liberty you know do
what you want with your body live your
life the way you want I just don't like
the idea that anyone who feels like
they're feminine if they're males should
you know alter their body I don't think
that's a good route for everyone yeah
you know the suicide rate post
transitioning is sort of interesting
because it's almost like a lot be a
certain amount of these people I would
assume they think that suddenly at the
end of that road is the golden ticket
right it's the pot of gold where all of
their problems are going to be solved
but there's still a lot of work to be
done after right yeah I mean transition
is just the beginning of your life you
know I didn't transition because that
was going to be you know the goal post I
transitioned because okay let me get
this out of the way and then focus on my
career and focus on living my life and
just being a normal person um I think
that a lot of people you know I've been
pretty lucky that transitioning didn't
come super difficult for me um I had the
means to you know do what I wanted to do
and I'm still doing what I want to do
but for a lot of people their entire
life is working their minimum wage job
and saving up for a surgery that costs
$50,000 and all these treatments and
what they realize when they're done with
that is well not much has actually
changed physically yes but my life is
still in the gutter I've emptied my bank
accounts doing this and [ __ ] still sucks
for me right that that's really kind of
fascinating I don't think people frame
it that way usually so like you
literally have your life you have
whatever job you have whatever friends
you have you save up all of this money
you still have sort of the same problems
you may be in in the body you want to be
but the physical part of your life and
your finances and all that and your
family or all that that's still all the
same so there's still a lot that has to
be done yeah there's so much more to
life than you know what you look like
and I'm not trivializing transgender as
I'm like it's just about what you look
like but at the same time transition is
just changing what you look
and there's just so much more to life
yeah it's interesting you use the word
normal a second ago which I know in this
conversation sometimes when you say that
to people you say well they they just
want to be normal or I just want to be
normal or that but that triggers people
that phrase normal but I'm guessing it
doesn't trigger you because you used it
so it's it's okay yeah yeah I mean I
will be the first to say being
transgender is abnormal it's abnormal
it's it's not common it's your if you're
transgender you're an extremely small
minority it's not it's just not
mainstream so um but I don't think that
abnormal is necessarily a negative
descriptor I just think it's not the
status quo it's just not the status quo
yeah I like that so let's talk about how
it's sort of become mainstream because
very quickly you know it seemed to me
that for for gay rights although it
obviously took a long time suddenly
within like a five year span it became
like cool and then marriage happened and
it's all good now you know I mean yes
there's still there's still problems of
course but you know it's it's pretty
good for gay people in most Western
societies certainly in America right now
not to say it's perfect but it's pretty
good the trans the trans issue happened
so quickly on the heels of gay marriage
a lot because of Caitlyn Jenner so what
did you make of just sort of the I guess
the transitioning of Caitlyn Jenner
someone doing it so publicly and then
also the just the media thing that went
on behind that yeah you know it was
really interesting for trans people to
watch that go down I mean it was like
watching I don't even know what but what
was really interesting to me was when
Caitlyn Jenner came out she was heralded
as this like brave amazing person she
was beautiful she was studying she was
just everything people wanted in the
trans person and then she sort of
started opening her mouth and people
realize like oh she's still a
conservative yeah she's a Republican
which is worried that's worse than being
trans it is it is well that's a lot
later but it is yeah and people turn on
her completely she's the most hated
person because before it was just like
the super far-right conservatives that
were like
I don't like that now with everyone
because everyone hates me you know
everyone hates conservatives there
weren't any right I guess conservatives
don't hate conservatives I think most
people secretly don't but this this PC
machine has us all tricked into into who
we hate but we'll get to that in a
little bit do you think there's a risk
when when something happens so quickly
this is partly what I've seen that
people didn't know much about trans
issues because as you said it's a it's a
very very tiny minority now I would be
for protecting any minority in any way
that you can but that when something
becomes so public so quickly that
everyone kind of goes crazy about it so
for in the Caitlyn example it's like she
came out and then it was like everybody
suddenly was the trans Ally and trans
hero and it was almost it seemed like
virtue signalling more than something
that seemed real to me oh absolutely I
mean listen I think that as a trans
person you can't have this expectation
that everyone is going to a understand
you because how could they and be accept
you because why would they it's
literally it's just being trans like I
said earlier there's so much more to
being a person like for me someone being
trans or not being trans or being
straight or being gay it's like okay but
what do you do like who arguing what are
your actual virtue is beyond
trans is amazing and everyone should
accept it what are your real virtues
that's what's important to me it's
almost like you care about the
individual what a radical thought yeah
yeah definitely
total radical thought all right so
obviously if we're talking about trans
issues we have to talk about the the
bathroom law in North Carolina when I at
the top of the show I sort of laid it
out for everybody and I'm guessing
you're not you're obviously not for the
law correct I'm not for or against the
law I genuinely I feel like I'm speaking
for a lot of trans people right now I
don't usually feel comfortable saying
now that I speak for anyone but I feel
like in saying this I'm comfortable
saying this most people don't care most
of us do not care who's going into what
bathroom etc I think that both sides of
the political spectrum really you know
brought this into something that it
really didn't need to be I mean trans
people have used the bathrooms for as
long as theirs
laughing tonight and no one's had an
issue um I don't know the left was
pushing wanting like gender-neutral
bathrooms which is a war trans people
did not ask them to fight we don't want
in a neutral bathrooms we just want to
use the regular bathrooms we don't want
to you know find businesses for not you
know spending all their money to build
these new bathrooms and the right with
making it seem like you know this huge
rapist area which was also fallacious it
was just all so silly to me just like
the Kalin thing it's interesting as a
trans person to sit and watch the media
circus around these issues when I'm just
living my life yeah you're just trying
to live your life and as you said I love
the way you frame that and it's art it's
partly what I said at the top of the
show but it's like you and every other
trans person for a long time has been
using whatever bathroom they felt was
appropriate and as far as I know there
wasn't some massive problem related to
this so you have a Republican
legislature that makes it a problem and
then you have the federal government
come in and say well we're going to
start cutting funding if you don't do
what we want and I don't think you're
for bigger government in a case like
this either right no absolutely not and
you know that's an important thing to
note because the left like I said often
fights wars that we don't ask them to
and for instance in New York Bay I
believe have started finding people for
not using proper pronouns and that's not
even just including key and sheets like
ziens earns them is right okay it's like
trans people already have an
unemployment rate that's I think like
three or four times the national average
and so you're really screwing over trans
people by pushing this you know virtue
legislation but basically by adding you
know a liability on the head of anyone
they want to hire that might be trans
yes they often screw over the people
that they're claiming to fight for in
their co-opting yeah I mean I'm pretty
sure you know my feelings on this
because this is what the left has done
in a lot of ways so really this does
this strike you as sort of the road to
hell is paved with good intentions I I
believe that a good portion of the
people on the Left that are pushing for
all this stuff they think they're
helping people like you yeah but but in
a weird way they're actually
objectifying you
ultimately what becomes bigger
government and more control yeah I mean
as much as I make fun of ashtray w's on
my channel and I think that a lot of
them do have their hearts in the right
place I just think that they go about it
completely wrong and they actually like
you said do harm the people their
co-opting a lot more than they help them
okay so with the with the law out of the
way and sort of your personal story out
of the way before we get to a whole
bunch of other stuff which is the stuff
that I really want talk about is there
anything else directly related to the to
being trans or the public idea of trans
or any of that but maybe I might have
missed here that that the average person
isn't thinking about well I think you
know something I say in a lot of
interviews is that there seems to be
this misconception that transgenderism
is the offspring of third wave feminism
of this you know riots and social
justice this but it's not the case trans
people have been around long before
otherwise of the SJW is along before a
third wave feminism and it's not you
know a feminist issue it's just people
like I've been saying yeah okay so you
transition your your when when were you
actually finish transitioning around 20
um it's kind of weird to think like
finish transitioning I mean I mean it
can always be things that you want to do
but in terms of just living my life
woman me then yeah I accomplished that
probably within six months of starting
so that's pretty quick okay so you do
that and now you as you said you're 22
years old when did you decide that I'm
going to be someone that talks about
this it's one thing to live my life as
you said but now you either I'm going to
put myself out there and I'm going to
take pretty unpopular opinions or at
least opinions that are contrary to what
the media will constantly push a trans
person should be like well I decided to
start my channel because I was like I
said earlier which is sick of being
co-opted I was sick of actually w's
having this monopoly on anything trans I
mean anyone who wants to check it out
now Google anything to do with
transgenderism the only things that pop
up pretty much besides some actual
scientific studies are you know tumblr
pages and you know leftist media
I didn't like that my identity was being
you know politicized by them so that was
kind of the main reason and then also
you know they're just topics I find
interesting you know I actually don't
talk about transgenderism that much on
my channel yeah I feminism Islam black
lives matter a lot of different things
so it was kind of just a means to speak
my mind yeah all right well we're gonna
we're going to dive into all that stuff
don't worry about I'm not letting you
get out of here without going into some
of that stuff at least we can travel
yeah well if you get into trouble it's
on you not on me but so when you decided
to do the public part of this how did
you have any pushback from friends or
family or were you concerned about your
safety at all or anything like that
oh you mean YouTube yeah once you
decided to put these videos out there
yeah yeah stuff went down when I started
my youtube um people often comment on my
channel saying like oh you're trans so
you can say all these things that I
can't say as a straight white male
actually I think it's the opposite I
think I get way more blowback because
I'm trans and I am speaking out against
you know Ashley W is I think that they
often see me as a traitor of sorts and
so the amount of how I got from
shredding YouTube was crazy I lost a ton
of friends I have feminists trying to
get me a victim from my apartment at the
time my roommates were awful to me so it
wasn't easy starting it but luckily I'm
in a good situation now living with my
boyfriend and I can do my videos and
whatever but definitely push back yeah
isn't that interesting the so-called
tolerant side once you start speaking
about what you as an individual thing
suddenly not so tolerant huh yeah yeah I
mean they have they have this whole
spiel about like supporting trans voices
and making trans voices heard but really
they mean trans wishes if they're on my
side of the political spectrum that's
what they really mean right so in a way
Kalin Jenner for you really has has
blazed two trails in a way by sort of
normalizing some trans stuff in general
but really on the political side I don't
think you're a conservative but you seem
to me that you're either a libertarian
or you're for freedom that seems to be
the general thing in your for the
individual but by her taking that
position as we said earlier kind of flip
there
on its head so she's really like blazing
trails all over the place which is
that's what you're supposed to do right
or am I wrong on that one what do you
think I don't know I think that she's
done more to harm and trans people to I
think that um I think that a lot of
conservatives don't like her I think
she's has a lot of really weird things
and just her behavior is really weird
and the fact that the biggest
conservative trans icon like killed
someone in a car crash I don't think
she's been super great well nobody's
perfect you know yeah no one's perfect
sometimes we just kill people on
accident but um you know I can't say
she's blades any trails for me I don't
think my life's been become easier or
harder because of her media presence I
think that I don't know yeah
she is what she is I think that she's
right about some things you know but she
she's Caitlyn she's right right right I
guess I guess really at the end of the
day this is the risk with any movement
when you when so much of it is based on
one person that person can't represent
everything for everybody as I don't
think you or as you've already said you
don't try to represent anyone other than
yourself no no if people feel like I'm
saying things that they want to say but
can't then that's great but I am solely
speaking for Blair that's why in this
interview when I'm talking about trans
stuff I don't want anyone to think that
I'm speaking as if as though it's some
sort of monolith and my experience with
everyone's because it's just not the
case yeah I'm curious so you mentioned
you have a boyfriend did he know that
you had transition before you met or did
he know who you were before you met or
how about that yeah everyone asked that
um no I told them with him I think like
the first 24 hours of talking to him
online and yeah he knew right away it
was it was after I started transitioning
yeah one other thing on the trance F and
then we're going to move into other
stuff I promise I've my friend Janet
mock who I've interviewed a couple times
you know Janet I don't know her
personally but I know but you know she
is yeah one of the things that she said
to me I had her on my old Sirius XM show
years ago before Caitlyn Jenner was out
when people really weren't talking about
trans stuff and one of the things she
said to me that I thought was
particularly interesting is that when
she transitioned that because she really
past she's really beautiful and because
of that it makes the experience that
much easier because people aren't
constantly looking at her and
questioning and that and that's only
going to happen to a really pretty small
amount of people do you think that's
fair to say yeah and and so what does
that then do to the to the average
person you think that that transitions
because I think you're probably closer
to her side of that and I think a lot of
people probably transition and they're
looking for perfection on the other side
and it goes to what we said before about
their finding this pot of gold but it
never really can be there yeah I think
that um what we call passing just means
you know being able to live your life
and not being perceived as your original
sex um I think that it makes life easier
I think that a lot of the people who
don't past are the ones who seem to be a
lot of you know to have a lot of
bitterness but I mean it's kind of to be
expected I mean it does suck if you were
to live your life and just everyone is
looking at you strange everywhere you go
I mean for any reason trans or not if
you have some sort of deformity or
whatever it what's up
you